halloker erstmal du bist Bild hübsch
machst noch relativ gute Musik noch und
ja kommen wir zur ersten Frage die wäre
die erste Frage wäre anscheinend ist ja
der Mann nicht gut darauf zu sprechen
dass du dich für play ausgezogen hast
und warum machst du das dann wenn er
überhaupt nicht begeistert davon ist
genau und was hat dich dazu überredet ja
und das zweite Frage die zweite Frage
wäre ob wir die mal anrufen können also
ob wir deine Nummer bekommen also war
jetzt bisschen ernst gemeint
ja freuen wenn Du unsere Frage
durchstellst und danke schön e ihr seid
beide Hammer ja Ciao ja
Kinder ich kann nur eines sagen zu sowas
wie Playboy und mit die Reaktion meines
Mannes etc man muss im Leben schon das
machen was man selber möchte man man das
Leben ist voller Kompromisse in einer
Beziehung in einer Ehe muss man
natürlich schon diese Kompromisse auch
schließen aber das war einfach etwas was
ich machen wollte dementsprechend habe
ich einfach gesagt Schatz tut mir leid
es ist etwas was ich machen möchte und
dann habe ich es durchgezogen und im
Endeffekt hat das dann auch akzeptiert
und respektiert und jetzt findet er die
Bilder sogar ganz schön also das von
eurer kaskada mit der relativ guten
Musik du musst dir noch die Nummer geben
meine Handynummer natürlich Moment
0049 Pies
sorry